Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Hamdım,
piştim,
yandım
ve şu an burada karşınızdayım.
Ben bugün sizlere hayat kurtarmanın
en kolay yolunu anlatmaya geldim,
sevdiklerinizin hayatını
sigortalamaya geldim,
karşılığında aynı şekilde
yapmanızı rica etmeye geldim.
Bunu yaparken ben kendi
hikâyemden de sıkça bahsedeceğim.
Güzel, keyifli bir aşk hikâyesi
ve başlıyorum.
Bundan yaklaşık 14 sene öncesinde,
bir yazlık kasabada bu gördüğünüz bendeniz
dünyanın en güzel gözlerini gördü,
peşinden koştu, çok istedi, aşık oldu
ve ne şanslı ki o gözler de
o çocuğu kabul etti.
Dünyanın en güzel gözleri,
bence Dilara'nın gözleri.
Sonrasında şey diyenler oldu,
"Ya bu yaz aşkı mı, değil mi?"
Biz başından beri
öyle olmadığını biliyorduk.
Sevgimizin özelliği bence, bu tip
sevgileri yaşayan başka insanlar da var,
birbirimizi büyüterek seviyor oluşumuzdu.
Kavgalar ettik, tartıştık
ama hep daha fazla sevdik.
Bir önceki günden hep daha fazla.
Yıllar geçti, evlendik.
Ben bir yandan özel sektör çalışanıyım
ama daha uzun sivil toplum
gönüllüsü olmak üzere bir kariyerim var.
O dönem 2013 yılıydı,
biz devlet korumasında kalan
çocuklarla ilgili çalışıyoruz.
Haziran ayı 2013 yılının,
Twitter'da bir etiket gördüm,
#Efe'yeİyilikLazım,
ama böyle herkes paylaşıyor,
herkes binlerce on binlerce yüz binlerce
retweet'ler havada uçuşuyor.
Dedim herhâlde bununla ilgili bir şey
yapmasak da olur yani bu konu hakkında.
Üç ay geçti, aynı etiketi tekrar
gördüm ve yine trend olmuştu.
Efe'ye iyilik lazım,
maalesef Efe'yi kaybettik.
Şimdi Efe bir çocuk,
herkes bir şeyler yapmış gibi
hissediyorum ben.
Araştırdım, yani niye böyle oldu ki!
Yarım saat sonunda anladım,
Efe'nin kök hücre nakline ihtiyacı vardı.
Bunun için kök hücre
bağışçılarına ihtiyacı vardı,
çok fazla sayıda olması
gerekiyor bu havuzumuzun
ve ben o havuzda olmayan
insanlardan biriydim.
Çok içselleştirdim,
hemen Dilara'ya anlattım.
"Dilara hani böyle bir şey
görmüştük ya, konuşmuştuk üstüne."
Evet, dedi, gördüm.
"Ben de gördüm," dedi.
Aynı şeyleri hissettiğini o an
zaten bakışlarından anladım ben de.
Ertesi gün gittik örnek bıraktık.
Bizde şöyle bir şey vardır,
biz Türk toplumu olarak veya insanlık
olarak yani bir şeye üzülüyoruz,
gerçekten çok üzülüyoruz,
üzülmekteki samimiyete
gerçekten diyecek bir şey yok
fakat "üşengeç üzüntü"
diye bir kavram var.
Hani üzülmek yetmiyor, gitmek gerekiyor.
Dermanı olabileceğiniz bir dert var
ortada, harekete geçmeniz gerekiyor.
Hemen arkadaşlarımıza anlattık,
her gün birini götürüyoruz.
"Hadi gel, bu akşam seninle buluşalım.
Hem ne zamandır görüşmüyoruz."
Meseleyi anlatıyoruz ve tabii ki
kabul ediyorlar, örnek bırakıyorlar.
Sonra Dilara'yla konuşuyoruz yine.
Dedim ki, birilerinin
bir şey yapması lazım.
Bakın bu çok güzel bir sorudur.
Birilerinin bir şey yapması
lazım ve bu çok sorulur.
İkincisi pek az sorulur, ama ikincisi
olmadan ilki boşta kalacak bir sorudur.
Neden o birileri biz
olmayalım ki, diye sorduk
ve Belki de Sensin böyle ortaya çıktı.
Belki de Sensin ne yapar,
şimdi o kısma geçiyorum.
Belki de Sensin, 18-50
yaş arasındaki sağlıklı bireyleri
kök hücre bağışçılığına yönlendirmek
için gönüllü çalışan bir organizasyondur.
Kesinlikle kan toplamayız,
tamamen gönüllülük esasına göre
Kızılay'a yönlendirmede bulunuruz.
Sağlık Bakanlığı'nın verdiği
direktifler doğrultusunda çalışırız,
birlikte çalışırız, ortak çalışırız.
18-50 yaş arasında sağlıklı
bir bireyseniz kısmı süper.
"Aa ben zaten 17 yaşındayım,"
"Ben 52 yaşındayım," diyorsanız
kaçmayın, kaçamazsınız öyle söyleyeyim.
Anlatabilirsiniz.
Burada önemli olan iki mevzu var;
öğrendiğiniz zaman ertelememek
ve vazgeçmemek üzere bağışçı olmak,
olduktan sonra da insanlara anlatmak.
Süreç şöyle; gidiyorsunuz Kızılay'a,
3 tüp kan örneği bırakıyorsunuz,
kısa bir onay formu var
onu dolduruyorsunuz,
burada kritik nokta
iletişim bilginiz değişirse
lütfen Kızılay'ı arayarak haber verin
ve siz artık bir kök hücre bağışçısı
adayısınız, bir kahraman adayısınız.
Birinin ihtiyacı olduğu zaman da nakle,
bu arada kök hücre nakli lösemi,
lenfoma çeşitli kan hastalıklarından
tedavi gören kişilerin son şansı,
o kişi diyecek ki benim ihtiyacım var,
siz de oradaysanız buradayım senin
hayatını kurtarmak için geliyorum.
Üç tüp örneği verdiniz,
eşleşmeyi bekliyorsunuz.
Telefonunuz çaldı,
büyük bir mutlulukla açtınız,
sizden tekrar örnek alınıyor.
Acaba işte doğru kişiden doğru örnekleri
doğru şekilde işleyebilir miyiz,
bir de biraz daha detaylı test yapıyorlar.
Sonrasında bir check-up
sürecine giriyorsunuz,
her şey tamamsa
bir nakil tarihi belirleniyor.
Burada insanların çok
korktuğu noktaya geliyorum.
Yani birtakım hurafeler maalesef
gerçeklerden daha hızlı yayılıyor.
İşte, matkapla alıyorlarmış gibi bir--
evet öyle bir şey kesinlikle yok.
Sağlık sektöründe önemli olan
önce sağlıklı insanın hayatını korumak.
Tercihinize bırakılıyor bu yöntemler.
İlki tercih oranı %10-%20 arası değişiyor,
benim favorim,
genel anestezi altında yapılıyor,
bir buçuk saat sürüyor ortalama işlem,
sizin kalça leğen kemiğinizden özel
bir iğneyle kök hücreleriniz alınıyor.
O gün isterseniz hastanede
kalabilirsiniz bir gün,
istemezseniz de kendinizi iyi
hissediyorsanız devam edebilirsiniz.
Diğer yöntem daha çok kullanılan,
dört gün boyunca size aşılama yapılıyor,
insülin iğnesi gibi düşünebilirsiniz
çok hafif bir aşı.
Bunun amacı da şu, kandaki dolaşım oranını
kök hücrelerin dolaşım oranını arttırmak.
Dört gün bitiyor ortalama,
beşinci gün de siz televizyon
koltuğuna uzanır gibi uzanıyorsunuz.
İki tane damar yolu açılıyor sizden,
bir damar yolunuzdan kanınız
çekiliyor kök hücreler ayrıştırılıyor,
diğer kolunuzdan size
geri veriliyor kanın geri kısmı.
Ortalama bu işlem de üç buçuk saat sürüyor
ve siz sırf bunu yaptığınız için
bir hayat kurtarmış oluyorsunuz.
Peki sorarım sizlere, çok mu zor bu işlem?
Değil.
Peki yapmazsanız ne oluyor?
Yapmazsanız binlerce kişi
hayatını kaybediyor,
bizde bir de şöyle bir söylem vardır
rahatlık vardır daha doğrusu,
"Nasıl olsa benim başıma gelmez."
İşte öyle olmuyor.
Hikâyenin devamını anlatayım sizlere.
Şeyi özellikle vurgulayayım,
bütün süreç ücretsizdir,
söylemeye gerek yok gibi
düşünüyorum gerçi ama belirteyim yine.
İdari izninize kadar Sağlık Bakanlığı
tarafından süreç yönetilir.
Şimdi biz Belki de Sensin'i kurduk,
2 sene geçti.
Büyüyoruz ama nasıl büyüyoruz,
hayallerimizin ötesinde bir iş oluyor.
Daha önce sivil toplumla çalışmışız ama bu
kez daha büyük bir ilgiyle karşılaştık.
Böyle şehirlere falan yayılıyoruz.
O dönemde dedik ki biz tamamlanmak
istiyoruz, aile olmak istiyoruz.
İşte Dilaram 32 haftalık hamile.
Doktor bana dedi ki,
"Dilara lenfoma."
Dedim ki, nasıl olur.
Biz Belki de Sensin ismini tasarlarken
tam olarak bunu düşünmüştük
ama bu kadarını tahmin etmiyorduk.
Birinin hayatını kurtaracak
kişi belki de sensin,
başına gelebilecek kişi de
belki de sensin.
Hayat sigortası derken vurgulamak
istediğimiz yer tam olarak bu.
Ne kadar kişiye anlatırsanız,
sevdiklerinizin hayatını
sigortalamış olacaksınız.
Tabii hastane süreci başladı,
çocuğumuz çok sağlıklı
bir şekilde doğdu Demir.
Adıyla yaşıyor, demir gibi
devam ediyor hayatına.
Biz 11 ay hastanedeydik,
burada da genelde
insanlar şey tahmin eder,
çok büyük acılar yaşanıyor içeride.
Evet çok ciddi bir tedavi var,
tahmin edemezsiniz bir insanın
kaç litre kemoterapi ilacı alabileceğini.
Söyleseler şaşırırsınız,
boşverin duymayın da zaten.
O kısma evet, ama biz orada
birbirimize aşık olmaya devam ettik.
Ne yapıyorduk,
birbirimizle şakalaşıyorduk.
Arkadaşlarımız geliyordu,
onlarla sohbet ediyorduk.
Onun dışında ben sürekli yanındaydım
Dilara'nın 7/24 refakatçisi bendim.
Serum askısını alıyorduk,
üçümüz dans ediyorduk
çünkü o an ve çoğu an ilaç
alması gerekiyordu hastanedeyken.
Çok zor anlar da oldu.
Bir tanesini söyleyeceğim, şu yüzden
söylüyorum sizi üzmek için değil,
bir an önce harekete geçin
diye anlatmak istiyorum.
Ben üç kez öğrendim --
üç kez söyledim Dilara'ya
sevgilime kanser olduğunu
bu dudaklardan, o da üç kez duydu.
Söylemesi çok ağır bir şey,
duymasını tahmin bile edemiyorum.
İki kez çünkü bilincini
kaybetmişti hastanede
ve aynı süreci üç kez
yaşamak durumunda kaldı,
aynı kabullenmeyi de.
Şimdi vurgulamam gereken
birkaç yer var,
hikâyeye devam edeceğiz.
Bize diyorlar ki,
"Canımız çok yanar mı?"
Evet, yalan söyleyemeyiz.
Lösemili bir çocuğun bir sene
boyunca gördüğü tedaviyi hayal edin,
onun beş dakikası kadar
yanar canınız.
Diyorlar ki, "Kök hücrelerimiz biter mi?"
Bitmez, kök hücre zaten kendini
en hızlı yenileyen hücrelerden bir tanesi.
Yine diyorlar ki,
daha kızdıklarıma geleyim,
"Beni kan tutar, ben gidemem."
Tamam seni kan tutar, bırak tutsun.
Seni tutacak kan bir başkasını
hayatta tutacaksa, lütfen tutsun.
Sonra başka ne var,
"Ben kan verirken bayılıyorum."
Ya yapmayın,
ölmekle bayılmayı
karıştırıyorsunuz, karıştırmayın.
Yani siz bayılacaksınız diye, öteki
taraftaki insan hayatını kaybetmesin.
11 ay sürdü bizim hastane sürecimiz.
Belki de Sensin ekibi
inanılmaz bir şekilde arkamdaydı,
hepsine ne kadar teşekkür etsem az.
Hâlâ birlikteyiz.
11 ayın sonunda Dilara bu
dünyadan ayrılmak zorunda kaldı.
Ben bu dünyada kaldım.
Ne yapmak istediysek
başımıza geldi, öyle oldu.
Dilara'nın bir sözü var,
"Ben hiçbir şey yapmadım,
her şey benim başıma geldi."
Ama şöyle düşünüyorum,
benim diğer sevdiğim insanlar da hayatta
ve Dilara tarafından
çok güzel sevilmiş birisi olarak,
sevmeyi ondan öğrenen
ona öğreten birisi olarak
geri adım atamazdım,
anlatmaya devam ediyorum.
Bizim hikâyemiz de
biraz şiirdeki gibi oldu:
"Tahir olmak da ayıp değil,
Zühre olmak da,
Hatta sevda yüzünden
ölmek de ayıp değil,
Bütün iş Tahir ile Zühre olabilmekte,
yani yürekte."
(Alkış)
Size biraz Belki de Sensin'in geldiği
noktadan bahsetmek istiyorum.
Şu an 15 şehre yayılmış
durumdayız kontrollü bir şekilde,
hızlı bir şekilde yayılıyoruz.
Harika bir insan topluluğuna sahibiz,
yüzlerce firmaya kök hücre
bağışçılığını anlattık.
Yüz yüze anlatımın daha etkili
olduğunu düşünüyoruz.
Yine onlarca üniversitede çıktık,
binlerce kişiye anlattık.
Üç aydır da çiçeği burnunda bir derneğiz.
Bizim tüzüğümüzün ana değerleri;
Dilara'nın vurgulamak isterim
bir hastane odasında,
o süreçteyken oğluma
aşılayacağım değerler diye
bir Instagram paylaşımından geliyor.
Onlar da şunlar:
Dürüst ol, vicdanlı ol, ahlaklı ol.
Ölümler için üzül,
hem de onlardanmış
bunlardanmış demeden üzül.
Kimsenin acısına "Oh olmuş," deme.
Ölümün değil, yaşamın
kutsandığı bir dünyaya inan.
Vurguluyorum, ölümün değil,
yaşamın kutsandığı bir dünyaya inan.
Ben, Aykut Kadir Kurt,
biz Belki de Sensin,
ölümün değil, yaşamın kutsandığı
bir dünyaya inanıyoruz.
Sizden istiyoruz, lütfen
insanlara yaşama fırsatı verin,
lütfen kök hücre bağışçısı olun,
herkese de anlatın.
Dinlediğiniz için teşekkürler.
(Alkış)